como a indústria têxtil e de moda pode
contribuir para a sustentabilidade é a
moda é feita de ciclos
muitos de vocês que não trabalham com
isso não deve ter escutado essa frase
mas pra quem faz parte da realidade da
indústria têxtil e de moda é bastante
comum e para contextualizar um pouquinho
pra vocês é essa essa frase eu vou falar
um pouquinho da história do vestuário e
da da indústria têxtil a então a nos
primórdios da humanidade a os seres
humanos eles passaram a se vestir com
peles de animais com o intuito de se
protegerem de de necessidades
fisiológicas mesmo como o calor o frio
as chuvas
o próprio sol e naquela época já havia
erotização das tribos onde os líderes
das tribos eles utilizavam pele de
animais que eram extremamente difíceis
de serem cassados
anos mais tarde essas peles elas foram
substituídas por matérias primas
vegetais
porém as camadas de peças de roupas elas
passaram a se tornarem mais pesadas mais
volumosas mas cumpridas
no entanto com o passar do tempo com o
advento das guerras com as tarefas
diárias que as mulheres precisavam fazer
dentro dos seus lares
até porque naquela época as roupas das
mulheres pesava cerca de 12 a 15 quilos
então era muito difícil por conta do
peso e do volume para que elas
conseguissem fazer essas atividades e
logo depois também pela inserção da
mulher no mercado de trabalho essas
camadas de roupas precisaram se tornarem
menores precisarão é se tornarem mais
leves para que elas tivessem esse essa
maior facilidade no dia de maior
conforto ao uso mesmo nessa época a
própria indústria que começou a surgir
de fast fashion ela tentou entender e
tentou utilizar alguns canais para poder
influenciar é ditadores de tendência
entenderam que naquela época os grandes
ditadores de tendências era a geração
jovem que vinha surgindo então eles
utilizaram a música o próprio cinema e
os ateliês de alta costura como canais
para atingir esse público mais engraçado
é que justamente esse público se
utilizou da moda no futuro pra tentar
protestar contra as diferenças sociais
contra os adultos contra tudo e contra
todos
a bem da verdade foi aí que surgiu o
movimento hip de uma pra cá se a gente
parar pra pensar há ainda são os jovens
que são os grandes ditadores de
tendência hoje com a intervenção maior
dos influenciadores digitais por meio da
internet então somos jovens que
realmente ditam a moda e não é à toa que
por conta da internet nós somos
bombardeados afogados diariamente com
essa é palavra tão conhecida é
ultimamente que é o consumo é comprar
cada vez mais quero agora compra agora
assim no meu ponto de vista a internet
ela realmente foi extremamente negativa
com esse nosso fácil acesso a comprar e
consumir querer cada vez mais no entanto
ela é a melhor forma de contextualizar
para a situação que a gente está vivendo
e fazer com que a gente tenha um acesso
à informação e não é à toa que a gente
consegue ter noção que hoje é é a os
arroios os lençóis freáticos lençol
freático o ar tatá sendo poluído é a uma
grande de munição ou até escassez da
fauna e da flora brasileira trabalho
escravo é a indústria têxtil moda hoje é
uma das mais lucrativas do mundo porém
também é uma das maiores geradoras de
resíduos e poluentes do mundo aqui tem
até alguns dados que corroboram isso que
eu tô falando ela emite na atmosfera
mais de 1 bilhão de toneladas de gás
carbônico por ano ela consome cerca de
98 milhões de toneladas de recursos não
renováveis por ano utiliza 93 trilhões
de litros de água por ano em seus
processos 20 por cento da poluição
aquática atribuída ao beneficiamento
têxtil
ea taxa de desperdício no setor da
confecção ela é de 15 a 20 por cento
sendo que mais de 50% da produção em
massa é descartar em menos de um ano e
apenas 13 por cento desses 50 é
reciclado
eu sei são dados extremamente alarmantes
e desmotivadores e não é à toa que a
sustentabilidade ela foi falada já tem
bastante tempo que foi na conferência de
meio ambiente em estocolmo e 72 e ela
foi definida como um conceito que busca
suprir as necessidades atuais dos seres
humanos sem interferir afetará gerações
futuras
só que a sustentabilidade muitas muitas
pessoas pensam que ela é embasada
somente e meio ambiente se trata só do
fator ambiental mas ela é baseada em
três pilares que é o ambiental
o econômico eo social ou seja o
ambiental é um terço daquilo que é o
todo que o todo da sustentabilidade
representa e assim desde que foi falar
em sustentabilidade pouco aconteceu
porém o atributo três fatores que foram
assim o estopim que foi aquela que lhe
momento que as pessoas acordaram e
pararam para refletir opa alguma coisa
precisa ser feito aqui que foi um fácil
acesso à informação é a denúncia de
trabalho escravo de uma grande varejista
do setor da moda e também é o acidente
num prédio onde funcionavam várias
confecções têxteis em bangladesh que
matou mais de mil trabalhadores desde
então começaram a surgir movimentos e
governamentais de estudiosos e
ambientalistas que realmente quiseram
fazer alguma coisa pra que as coisas
mudassem que o que fossem eliminadas ao
menos né e conceitos como slow fashion
consumo consciente consumo sustentável
brecht obra bazar de troca roupas
transformava as roupas reversíveis
inclusive até o vestido que eu estou
usando hoje ele é reversível
eles passaram a aaa ganhar espaço e isso
o instituto de pesquisa brasileiro a
catumbi ele começou a estudar quais eram
os gatilhos que realmente
é impulsionar vão as pessoas a mudarem
de um comportamento de uma vida normal
para uma vida sustentável
eles citaram como os três mais
importantes a mudança como forma de
evolução então as pessoas elas param
para refletir assim é puxa é eu eu
mudando para uma vida mais sustentável
eu tô fazendo mais pela sociedade por um
bem maior
enxergar a simplicidade como forma de
sofisticação né porque panamá é tá na
moda ser sustentável é chique ser
sustentável é o famoso - é mais como uma
boa oportunidade para contribuir para
uma causa e eu acrescentaria esses três
aspectos que seriam os aspectos sociais
e culturais modismos ea influência da
mídia na internet como a gente já citou
é o anteriormente
aqui no brasil a moda ela realmente está
ainda muito tímida ela tá a a moda
sustentável né e o ibope até listou uma
fez uma pesquisa com consumidores
brasileiros focados nessa área
e esses consumidores eles disseram que
eles possuem interesse na verdade 70%
falou isso então é uma uma percentagem
bastante é grande é em consumir
sustentabilidade mas que não estão
dispostos a pagar mais caro por isso e
de 70% boa parte disse que não acredita
em ações sociais ambientais por parte
das empresas é porque diz que é que a
mera jogada de marketing para realmente
vender mais ou seja de um lado a gente
tem uma demanda enorme por
sustentabilidade por consumo consciente
porém ao mesmo tempo a gente tem uma
insegurança muito grande então as
indústrias de têxtil e moda hoje eles
passaram a começar a entender isso
um ator que hoje estão surgindo muitas
fibras sustentáveis é muito provenientes
de cascas de alimentos como banana é
abacaxi existem fibras que são
provenientes da proteína do leite
provenientes de tudo aquilo que às vezes
a gente descarta né própria utilização
de compostagem mas que a gente não não
não tem um estudo maior acerca disso
além de demais ainda existem fibras que
são recicladas de garrafa pet fibras que
são recicladas de rede de pesca enfim
uma infinidade de fee fibras
provenientes de materiais que a gente
utiliza no nosso dia a dia que a gente
não tem noção que elas podem ser
reaproveitados para esse fim
além de indústrias que utilizam água de
reuso em seus processos e as marcas que
estão surgindo ultimamente o que eu
quero dizer que assim é é a indústria
não é não é indústria deixa ela não tá
mudando por conta de pressões midiáticas
por conta de ações governamentais ou
porque é time no hindu a matéria prima é
disponível enfim não é porque é bonito
você veio porque é bonita sustentar a
indústria ela pra ela é muito mais fácil
fabricada maneira convencional é menos
oneroso menos trabalhoso e eles lucram
mais ela está mudando porque nós
consumidores estamos mudando porque hoje
nós temos uma consciência de consumir
produtos mais duráveis mas sustentáveis
com uma maior qualidade muitas das
pessoas é estão dispostas e já pagam
mais caro por isso nós estamos mais
engajados com questões sociais questões
ambientais questões econômicas e
tecnológica isso nos faz é nos tornar
mais conscientes ao consumir
então é existe sim uma uma interessante
uma integração que tem que ser feita
entre os governos entre as indústrias
entre nós seres seres humanos para que a
indústria de peixe moda fique verde né
continue sendo é tendo essas ações
sustentáveis e como falei anteriormente
pra qq que essa mudança seja feita a
gente tem que lembrar que são os fatores
sociais ambientais e econômicos que
fazem parte da sustentabilidade
então assim é a gente não pode só se
esquecer
e nós fomos os precursores dessa mudança
nós consumidores fomos os precursores
dessa mudança
o que eu quero dizer é que eu coloquei
esse tema aqui porque era pouco tempo
para se falar para se falar mas eu
queria realmente provocar uma reflexão
em todos vocês porque a gente sempre
para olhar o outro lado a gente sempre
para refletir o lado das indústrias do
lado dos fabricantes e que eles estão
ganhando então lucrando mais e por isso
que eles estão ofertando produtos
sustentáveis bem independente de qual
seja a iniciativa ou porém o motivo que
a indústria está fazendo isso ela tá
querendo ofertar esses produtos para
nossa alma demanda e tendo demanda isso
vai fazer com que as indústrias querem
que irão competir nesse mercado
globalizado
então eu convido todos vocês a
refletirem um pouco sobre sobre isso e
disseminar em essa ideia e de fato serem
a mudança porque assim é eu sei como é
que vai dar sustentabilidade daqui cem
ou 200 anos mas eu tenho certeza que a
indústria de têxteis moda vai estar
presente porque afinal nós precisaremos
resistir mesmo pense nisso muito
obrigada
[Aplausos]